[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNIL ARORA: So today,
we'll be talking
about managing applications
the Kubernetes way.
Before we get started
with the session,
I would like to do a little
show of hands exercise here.
How many of you are
using Kubernetes
at work or in your setup?
Wow.
One word, how many of you
are using stateful workloads
in Kubernetes?
Great.
So this is actually a perfect
session for that, then.
So today I'll be talking
about how to extend Kubernetes
to manage your workloads on it.
So my name is Sunil Arora.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
I've been working with
Kubernetes for over two years.
I've contributed to projects
like kubectl, kustomize,
and most recently, I've
been focusing on Kubernetes
extensibility.
And I'm a tech
lead and maintainer
for the Kubebuilder project.
And with me, we
have Jun, Jun Tee,
who is a software
engineer at Google
working on the Kubernetes team.
So the way we have
structured our talk today
is first we'll be going over
some of the Kubernetes basics,
so the code patterns that we
use to write built-in APIs
and controllers.
And then we'll be looking
at some of the ways
to extend Kubernetes,
specifically
focusing on API extensibility.
And then we'll be diving into
Kubebuilder, the SDK, which
is how do you build
APIs and controllers.
And then the favorite part of
our session, which is the demo,
I will be showing you a SqlDB
operator example demo here.
And we'll try to give 5 to 10
minutes at the end for the Q&A.
So with that, let's get started.
I'll invite Jun to talk about
what is the Kubernetes way?
JUN TEE: Hello, everyone.
My name is Jun.
I am also a software
engineer at Google Cloud.
For the past few years
I work at Google,
I worked on Kubernetes
controllers and operators.
And I am eager to
date to share with you
all about the basics of
Kubernetes, which we will
cover in the first session.
Kubernetes, as you all know,
is a container orchestration
system that automates
deployment, scaling,
and management of
containerized applications.
It groups all the containers
belonging to an application
into logical units for easy
management and discovery.
It builds upon many years
of Google's experience
in running production workloads.
It is able to be run on
major public clouds like GCP,
AWS, Azure.
And with the latest
technologies,
it is also able to run
on the on-prem clusters.
It handles all the
common cluster routines,
like scheduling of the life
cycle, scaling, et cetera,
on behalf of users.
Kubernetes is an
API-centric system.
What this means
is that everything
communicates through the APIs.
The API server is the center
of universe in Kubernetes.
It powers all the APIs.
It serves the REST endpoints
supporting all the common CRUD
operations like create,
get, update, delete.
It also stores the API
resources, the objects,
in etcd.
Amongst all the
components in Kubernetes,
such as the [INAUDIBLE]
like kubectl,
the control print
component like scheduler,
and the node agent
like kubelet, have
to talk through the API server.
They have to send a request
to the server for processing.
Now, let us have a view
at the basic building
blocks of Kubernetes.
In Kubernetes, we have
this concept named pod.
A pod is basically a group
of tightly coupled containers
belonging to an application
and the shared volumes.
We group all the containers
of an application together,
and also the necessary
underlying volumes
within this pod.
And all the containers
within the pods
share the same life
cycle and phase.
So if you have one pod--
if a pod is down, all
the containers within it
is also down.
And the containers also share
the same IP and pod space.
They see each other
as localhosts.
There are three
types of containers--
the init containers,
main containers,
and sidecar containers.
Init containers perform
initialization routines
like creating data directory
or downloading the source codes
before the main
container is started.
The init container has
to be completed before we
can start the main container.
Main container is where the
real application is running.
For example, as an end user, if
I deploy a redis application,
the application will be run
between the main container.
And lastly, the
sidecar container
is a container that
provides additional routines
and functions to assist
the main container.
Some examples are monitoring
and logging sidecar.
One of the most important
features in Kubernetes
is that it allows the end
users to specify the desired
states, the target
states, the states
that they want of the
cluster to Kubernetes
using declarative APIs.
This means that the users
only need to tell Kubernetes
how many replicas do they want,
and Kubernetes will basically
do everything.
Perform the reconciliation
underneath automatically.
It's different
from imperative API
in which the users
have to provide
step-by-step instructions.
In Kubernetes, all the API
resources, all the objects,
have an API that can be broken
down into three components.
The first component
is metadata in which
you can put the name, namespace,
the labels, et cetera.
And the second
component is a spec.
Spec API fields is where the
users provide the desired
states that they want for
this particular API resource.
And lastly, the status field
is where the Kubernetes
will update the current
status, the current states
at a current point of
time of the API resource.
For example, what is
the number of parts
that are already ready at this
moment, and how many of them
is still not ready yet?
Now, let us go to
another important concept
in Kubernetes--
the controller.
A controller is the long
lived controlled route
that performs the
automatic reconciliation
on behalf of users.
The reconciliation is
made up of three steps.
First, the controller observe
the existing current states
of the cluster.
It then compares those states
with the desired states,
the declared states
provided by the users.
It deduces the
differences, and then it
acts upon the differences
by bringing the cluster
to the desired states.
For an example, let's
say we have a cluster.
And that cluster runs two
application instances.
However, the user
specified that there
is a need to have three
number of replicas
running at any given time.
So what happens here
is that the controller
will create another
replica to measure
that the total number
of replicas is always 3.
Similar thing happens, let's say
initially we have 4 replicas.
The controller will then delete
one of the extra replicas.
And now let us go over some
primitives in Kubernetes.
Primitives, or the built-in
controllers of Kubernetes,
is widely used for
running the applications.
I believe most of you
have already used them.
I will go through some of them.
The first one is ReplicaSet.
ReplicaSet is a
controller that maintains
a set of pods, of
identical pods,
at any given point of time.
It guarantees availability
of a certain number of pods.
If a pod is down, it
will always restart it.
The next control is deployment.
Deployment is a little
bit complicated,
but it is a higher
level controller
that provides declarative
updates for the ReplicaSets
and pods.
What happens is when a user
creates the primary source,
a corresponding
ReplicaSet or resource
will also be created by
the deployment controller.
And then the
ReplicaSet controller
that we mentioned just
now will create the pod.
Hence, the deployment controller
will manage all the pods
indirectly through the
ReplicaSet controller.
And lastly, it is the
StatefulSet controller.
A StatefulSet controller
is used specifically
for managing the
stateful applications.
When we mention about the
stateful applications,
we refer to those applications
that depends on the data states
to run the operations
accurately.
Yeah.
All the parts
within a StatefulSet
maintain a sticky identity.
That has a persistent
identifier that
will be given the same
throughout any re-scheduling
of the pod.
For the first part
of a StatefulSet,
we have the index number zero.
And for the second one,
we have one, and so on.
For the next session,
Sunil will guide us
through extending Kubernetes.
SUNIL ARORA: Let's
look at how Kubernetes
have evolved with respect
to running applications.
So initially, it started
with stateless apps,
which are very simple apps.
And if you look at the
operations involved
in managing the lifecycle of
stateless apps is on Day 0,
you would just orchestrate them.
And Day 2 would pretty much
require either scaling them
up or down, or would require
updating, which is a roll-out.
So those operations
are supported
by the existing primitives
like ReplicaSet and Deployment.
You can just use those,
and they are good enough
to run stateless workloads.
Now, moving on to
simple stateful apps,
these are apps which
are not distributed.
They are kind of
very simple to run.
So for that, StatefulSet
and CSI gives you
a good enough primitive
to run them successfully
for Day 0 and Day N operations.
Now, let's look at a
complex app, which is--
think of a distributed
application like a data
store or, let's say, a messaging
application like Kafka.
So on Day 0, it
involves orchestration,
which is setting up
the initial topology.
Day 2, typically that's where
the real trouble starts,
which is let's say you
want to take backup
or you want to restore.
Depending on the
application, application
may have its own storage
semantics for that.
Now, update might involve--
these applications have their
own clustering mechanisms,
so update might require a lot of
coordination between the nodes.
Similarly, when it
comes to scaling them,
which is you want to
adjust the topology,
so that would also require
coordination between the nodes.
It gets really complicated.
And so it goes on.
You want to reconfigure
the same thing.
So if you have such
an application--
now, this is beyond
Kubernetes knowledge
to provide primitives to operate
these independent applications.
So what would have
been really nice
if you could model
all these operations
of these complex applications
as declarative APIs.
And you can use the same
tooling like kubectl
to operate on them.
And so for example
here, it would be nice
if I were to launch
a DB instance.
I could just set, here is a
spec from my DB instance, which
is readReplicas is 2, storage
is I want this sort of storage,
I want backup to
be done weekly, I
want backupStorage to
be using slow disk,
and things like those.
And I can perform all those--
I can manage all
those operations
using the kubectl API--
sorry, tooling.
So Kubernetes doesn't
give you those primitives.
But it provides these
extension mechanisms
which you can use to build
such an experience on top
of Kubernetes.
So let's look at when
Kubernetes was started,
it was started with
the goal of being
just a container
orchestration system,
but over the years, what I've
been seeing last two years,
team and community has
put in so much effort
in making the system extensible.
And now it has evolved
into a platform.
So it provides constructs
which you can build on top of.
So when it comes to
running application,
it is just not running
application within Kubernetes.
It is a lot of stuff which
is around application which
people have to worry about.
It is policy enforcement.
It's more continuous deployment.
So I think with evolving
it as a platform,
I think there is a lot of pieces
that community has contributed
if you look at that is making
the whole platform really
powerful, as well.
So there are two dimensions
to extending Kubernetes.
One is infrastructure
extensibility,
which is extending it to
different hardware providers,
different storage providers.
The second is API
extensibility, which
is what we'll be
focusing on today.
So in the next few
slides, I'll be
covering the two main important
API extensibility mechanisms.
And then we'll go
back and reconnect
with the slide we talked
about earlier, how to manage
the complex application.
So the first primitive
is custom resource.
And you must have heard of
this term, CRD, everywhere.
So custom resource is another
API provided by Kubernetes
which allows you to introduce
your own API in the cluster.
And to give you an example--
so custom resource definition,
how do you do that?
So custom resource definition is
another declarative yaml file.
You specify the sort of
what I would call schema
for your custom resource.
Think of it as, let's say,
if you have a SQL database,
you would define--
when you create a table,
you define a schema,
and then you have
rows in the table.
In the similar way,
CRD is the definition,
is the schema for your API.
And custom resource
instance are--
think of them as the actual
instances for that resource.
So let's say once you
have this yaml file which
defines the schema
for custom resource
where you can specify the API
group diversion and the kind,
and then there are
additional features
that CRD supports, for
example, OpenAPI validation.
You can specify what
sort of validation
needs to be performed, then
printer column support,
which I'll cover later
when I do a live demo.
So the way to
think about this is
once you submit
this yaml file, then
Kubernetes API server gives you
this hosted endpoint service.
It will automatically
create a REST endpoint
for that API resource.
And now this API is available
to all the existing tooling
and clients in order to consume.
So the experience is
very similar to what you
will have for built-in APIs.
So the second primitive
extension point
that Kubernetes provides
is the admission webhooks.
So if you look at the lifecycle
of a request in the Kubernetes
API server, let's say an
incoming resource like Pod,
when it hits the
API server, it will
go through the series of
admission control plugins.
There are some built-in
admission control plugins,
but there are two new ones which
got introduced in last year
or so is validating webhook
and mutating webhook.
So let's look at one by one.
So validating webhook is
where Kubernetes API server
for each incoming resource
can make a request
to an external HTTP web service.
And that service can say
whether to accept or reject
this incoming resource.
Now, this can be
used to implement
some very powerful mechanisms.
Like, let's say you want
to enforce certain policies
in your system, which
a simple example would
be you want to allow only
certain images to be running
in Kubernetes.
So this would be
one way to do it.
Let's look at another
extension point,
which is mutating webhook.
So let's say you have an
incoming resource, like Pod,
and Kubernetes API sort of
will call another HTTP API
service which can mutate the
spec of the incoming resource.
So in this case, let's
say you can modify the Pod
and then it will be
persisted in that [INAUDIBLE]
after going through.
So the modification--
this enables
some of the really
powerful use cases.
One would be, let's say there
are things that you want
to do across your applications.
One would be let's say you
want to inject a sidecar
container for log collection.
So you can do such a thing
using mutating webhook.
Or let's say for
some other-- let's
say Istio is one where they use
sidecar injection for the NY
proxy and things like those.
So another thing where
mutating webhook is used which
is for defaulting.
So if you have an
API and user has not
specified certain
fields and you want
to put in some
sensible defaults,
that would be another use
case for mutating webhook.
So we covered CRD and we
covered admission webhook.
And now let's go back
and reconnect the dots
with how do you manage a complex
application which is very--
which has-- managing
Day 2 operations
are very unique to
that application.
So you take these
three building blocks.
First is we use the CRD to
introduce the declarative APIs.
Then you take all that
operational knowledge
of your application which
might be sitting either
in playbooks or some
bunch of bash scripts,
or maybe sometimes
in wiki pages.
So you can take that
operational knowledge,
put that in the
controllers, and with that
you will have a working API
to manage your application.
And now optionally, you
can use admission webhooks.
Now, when it comes to
orchestrating and managing
all the workflows
related to application,
you can leverage all the
Kubernetes primitives.
For service discovery,
you can use the services.
You can use Pod,
StatefulSet, or ReplicaSet
for orchestrating what I call
as infrastructure programming.
You can use secrets
and conflict map
for conflicts and
credential management.
So you don't have to reinvent
the wheel over there.
And if you look at
some of the building
controllers are
also done like that.
ReplicaSet is built
on top of pods
and deployment is built
on top of ReplicaSet.
And so there is a hierarchy
of resources there.
And once you have that,
you use the existing tools
like kubectl to manage
the application.
So to the end users, it's
built-in API, pretty much,
for them.
And that's the whole idea.
And you get all
the other features
like authorization,
authentication, and auditing
that comes with
the API for free.
So now we know that, OK, these
are the primitives available
and you can build your custom
controllers, application
controllers, to manage
your application,
now let's look at
how we can do that.
So in this section, we'll be
talking about Kubebuilder.
So Kubebuilder is an open source
project under Kubernetes org.
It's actually a subproject
of special interest group API
machinery.
So the project was
started about a year back
and we looked at
the state of the art
for writing custom
controller at that point.
And it was very complex.
So you need to have deep
understanding of low level
Kubernetes APIs to write
something workable.
And it required a lot
of copying and pasting
of code, which was
very error prone.
And the documentation
also was very fragmented
and all over the place.
So we looked at that problem and
we said, how can we solve it?
How we can make it really
easy to extend Kubernetes?
How we can take all those
extension points and let people
bring their expertise
of writing, managing
the application and
pair it together
with the extension
points and make
it easy to extend Kubernetes.
So let's look at some other
components of Kubebuilder
project.
So the three main
components-- on top you
have this Kubebuilder CLI,
which bootstraps a user project.
And the day to day flow of
either bootstrapping or adding
new APIs and
controllers or updating
the dependencies in
the projects as done
by the Kubebuilder project.
And then there are
two components,
controller-tools and
controller-runtime,
which are used by the user
project itself to implement
the APIs and controllers.
So let's look at the tools.
What do they do?
So the first is when
you want to-- let's
say you decided to write
an API and controller.
You would start with
an empty directory
and you would like to
bootstrap the project.
So the first set of commands
which sets up the dependencies,
sets up the right
directory structure
looking at some of the
things that we have learned
over the past years by
writing custom controllers,
so we have baked those
all in these tools.
So what would the make
or Dockerfile look like?
And we'll scaffold the makefile,
which would pretty much have
most common targets
that you would
use in day-to-day development
of your controller.
Then when it comes to
adding APIs and controllers,
scaffolding some of
the boilerplate code
automatically for
you, writing them
up with the right set
of underlying clients
and libraries.
So this is the part
which Kubebuilder does.
And then the
controller tools is--
so like we discussed
about CRDs are
the way to introduce your API.
So it has tools to
generate the CRDs.
So the tools basically look
at the type start code.
And we'll show you in the
demo how that is done.
And then generation of the CRDs.
Then the last part, which
is when-- let's say you
have your controller ready.
You want the manifest
that you need
for deploying in Kubernetes.
So you have tools for
generating those, as well.
And then this is the
most important component
of Kubebuilder, which is
the controller-runtime.
Like I discussed before,
the state of the art
was copying and
pasting the code.
So we looked at some
of the common patterns
that you have to do when
you're writing controllers.
For example, you want to
observe certain resources
in Kubernetes.
Then you want to
invoke reconciliation.
You want to run this active
reconciliation loops.
You want to run a number
of threads over there.
And so all those are
some of the things
that are common patterns.
We abstracted them out and
provided some intuitive APIs
to use that so that
users don't have
to worry about this low
level-- underneath it
uses the low level Kubernetes
upstream client libraries,
but you get the more
intuitive patterns
that you can directly apply.
Then another is,
very similarly, we
extended it to
admission and conversion
webhooks, which are the APIs.
And then the third part,
which we have seen,
is about the providing
a dynamic Kubernetes
client which can work with
any Kubernetes resource.
So that also makes
things really easier
to understand because now you
have a very less API surface
area when it comes to client,
which can talk to any resource.
So essentially, the whole
idea is that we're still
iterating over these libraries.
And as we're learning more and
more about the best practices,
we're trying to bake them
either in the code library
or as in utility functions
that people can use.
And so another
example is like when
you're running your
controller in the production,
you want access to all the
metrics to debug any production
scenario.
So the controller-runtime
library automatically
provides other metrics like
the reconciliation errors,
the number of
reconciliation, what
is the backlog queue that you
have, and the reconciliations.
Things like those are
automatically supported.
So I think with that, can
we switch to the terminal?
So we would look at some
of the Kubebuilder flow.
And I will also show
you controller-tools
and controller-runtime
abstracts.
So let's get started.
OK.
So right now, we
are in a directory
which we have already
bootstrapped for our project,
the SqlDB operator.
And so let's say you have
downloaded Kubebuilder
release on your laptop.
And after that what you
will get is Kubebuilder CLI
on your command
prompt, so you can
basically-- they're not
much commands, actually,
if you look at.
So the first thing that you want
to do is you want to invoke--
you want to bootstrap
your project.
So the way to do it would be--
I've already done
it, so I'm just
going to show the command here.
So you just run
Kubebuilder in it,
which will initialize
your project.
It takes a bunch of
parameters, like you
can specify the license
that you want to include,
what are the owners
you want to use
in the copy header that shows
up at the top of the file.
Then once you have
that, what you'll see
is it will scaffold the
project structure for you.
So this is pretty
much the structure
that every Kubernetes project
that you'll see follows.
And so let's look at very
quickly some of the things
that it did for us.
So it sets up the
go dependencies.
You see the Gopkg.lock
and Gopkg.toml
package terminal
file, which is--
we're using Godep for
managing dependencies.
So we set that up automatically
so that all the Kubernetes
dependencies gets
pulled for you.
So that gets pulled in
the vendor directory here.
Then look at we
automatically create
Dockerfile, scaffold
the Dockerfile,
which we'll use for building
the controller image that we
can run it in cluster.
Then we scaffold the Makefile.
I can quickly show
you the Makefile.
So Makefile has some
of the common targets
that you'll be working.
So one example would
be you'll be scoping--
let's say you want to run test.
You want to build
the manager binary.
You want to run.
You want to install
CRDs in the cluster.
You want to deploy the manifest.
You want to, let's say,
clean up all the manifest
that you deployed.
So all these common
workflow, it automatically
is available right off the
bat when you run that command.
Then let's show you a
little bit of the code.
So we'll scaffold
the main.go, which
is the entry point for your
controller, where it will read
the config, which
is a Kubernetes
config, whether you're running
on locally or in the cluster.
It will automatically
set that for you.
Create the controller
manager, which is basically
a shell, you can
think, which is going
to host all these controllers,
a set of controllers.
Because when you're
writing API, you will be--
you can have multiple set
of controllers to power
the same API, performing
different functionalities.
So then in the end, you
just invoke mgr.Start here.
So let's go back.
Now let's look at--
so up to now, let's say
this is the bootstrapping
of the project.
Then the next step would
be you want to add an API.
Add API step would be you
just run this command.
Like in this case, we wanted
to add an API called SqlDB.
We wanted to add v1alpha1.
So we invoke
kubebuilder create api.
And now it will scaffold out the
API and the controller files.
So let's very quickly
go over those.
So pkg is where APIs and
controller code lives.
So in the APIs, you have
infra and the v1alpha1.
So let's look at
one of the files.
This is your types.go
for the Kubernetes API.
Now, it will start with--
so this is our first
API, and it's SqlDB.
Like Jun explained earlier,
every Kubernetes API
have these fields.
Like, it will have the TypeMeta
information, the ObjectMeta
information, which is
basically the metadata and type
meta, and then the Spec,
and then the status.
So Spec is where it is
all application dependent.
What are the fields you want
to take as input from users?
So like in this
case, the database
type, the version of the
database that you want to run.
And then you can
have different fields
for the topology
you want to set up,
like the replicas and
the disk you want to use,
things like those.
So while we are here,
I wanted to show--
we talked about how
controller-tools
is one of the tools
that takes your types.go
and it generates CRD schema.
So you will see that these are
Kubebuilder directives that you
can specify in the code here.
It's like, here I'm using
a feature of CRD which
is printcolumn feature, which
lets you decide what columns
you want to print by default
when a user performs kubectl
get on that resource.
Like, for parts you
see certain columns.
For your own resource
you want to show--
you want to
customize the output.
So this is where you
configure the feature for CRD,
and controller-tools is
going to take this as input
and generate the CRD yaml files.
For example, I can
quickly show the config
for this API, the CRD.
So the CRD definition for
SqlDB API that we added is--
so this has generated, for
example, the name of the CRDs
here, like the PrinterColumn
spec that I showed you earlier.
This got generated
in the form of here.
So it's saying that, OK, show
replica is one of the columns.
And this is the JSONPath
for extracting that value
that you want to show.
So there are other features.
Like, similarly, if you
want to add more validation,
you can annotate the
fields in your types.go
with the open API
specific annotations.
And the controller
tools are going
to generate the schema
automatically for you.
So this way, your code is
in sync with the CRD schema.
So yeah, that was quick
about the CRD schema.
And then we can look, just
very briefly, at the controller
code, as well.
So your controller code
is-- like, in this demo,
we have two controllers,
so sqldb and sqlbackup.
So sqldb.controller
here is where--
so we'll see the
controller-runtime,
the library part that
I talked about earlier.
So this is what--
we are importing that
and we are using--
so the first thing
controller wants
to do is being able to
watch, observe the resources.
So you will see that this
requires just a simple--
so we have these
high level APIs where
you can say, I want to watch
this resource of kind this,
or in this case,
the three objects
that we care about is the sqldb.
And sqldb basically uses
StatefulSet and services
for orchestrating the SqlDB.
So we are watching those
resources, as well.
And then some of
the things where
you can set up the ownership
hierarchy, which is--
with just a few lines
of code here, it
will automatically set up--
OK.
It will trigger write
objects that gets cued
in the reconciliation--
for reconciliation.
Now let's look at quickly how
reconciliation code looks like.
So typically, all
you need to do is
if you add your
watches correctly,
then you can just focus
on the reconcile function.
And here, this will
actually depend
on the complexity of the
application you're managing.
Like, in this case, you will
first get whatever resource
you need to reconcile.
You want to probably default if
this resource was not created
on the set of the defaults.
You can do validation,
also, here.
So yeah, this code will--
I will not actually go
through this code in detail.
So let's skip this.
This is where controller
and API code is organized.
So I think now this
would be the right time
to switch to the next
part, where let's look
at the SqlDB operator.
So Jun would be
giving us the overview
how the SqlDB operator that we
wrote for this demo is set up.
So Jun?
JUN TEE: Thanks Sunil for the
explanation about Kubebuilder.
In this session, we will
show how Kubebuilder
is used to create
a simple operator,
a simple stateful
operator named SqlDB.
Before diving deep
into the demo,
I wish to provide a
high level overview
of what the operator does.
The operator creates and
manages a Postgres cluster.
It's comprised of two APIs.
Like Sunil said, it's a SqlDB
API and a SqlBackup API.
The SqlDB API is
used for the creation
and restore of the
Postgres clusters,
while the SqlBackup API is
used for backup the data
of the cluster.
Underlying all the Postgres
cluster created by the operator
we have a shared storage
layer underneath.
We use a network file system
to start a backup file,
and then retrieve the backup
file for the restoration
purpose.
We run the operator
between a GKE cluster
and create the manifest to
create the SqlDB and SqlBackup
resources.
Our demo workflow
is very simple.
It's comprised of
only three steps.
The first step is to create
a SqlDB resource to roll out
a cluster and wait for
the Postgres cluster
to become ready.
And then we populate
the data to it.
Please know that for
simplicity reasons, in our demo
we have only stacked one
Postgres database instance.
So a cluster means only
one instance of a database.
And in a second session, we
will create a SqlBackup resource
to trigger the backup
of data that we inserted
into the cluster in step 1.
And lastly, we will create
another SqlDB resource
to roll out another cluster.
And we will verify that
the data of the old cluster
can be restored to
a second cluster.
Yeah.
Now let us go over the workflows
for the Postgres database
instant creation.
What happens here is that the
users create a SqlDB resource.
When the controller
observe the creation event,
the controller creates
a StatefulSet resource.
Within spec of the
StatefulSet resource,
we specify the Postgres
as the container image.
And then the
StatefulSet controller,
one of the primitives that
we went over in session one,
creates the pods.
And within the pod, there
is the main container
running the Postgres database.
And we use a Postgres-specific
client, named psql,
to assess the container.
This is done through a
Kubernetes service resource.
This service is the
[INAUDIBLE] service
that has post the
container to the client.
And all of this information
is hidden from the end users.
All the end users have
to do is very simple.
Just by running the kubectl
apply, the manifest file,
all the users have to do is
to create the SqlDB resource
and that's it.
For the Backup flow, what the
users can do with the operator
is that he or she can
create a SqlBackup resource.
The backup resource
has a reference
back to the SqlDB
resource they created
in the previous workflow.
And with this information,
the SqlBackup controller
is able to identify
which container that it
wants to run a command with.
The controller
will run a command
within the container to
trigger the backup utility
to perform as the backup.
What happens here is
that a backup file
will be created by
the utility and stored
into the underlying
network file system.
Please note that for
the network file system,
we can substitute
it for other storage
mediums, such as the Google
Cloud storage and the Amazon S3
and Azure storage.
It is interchangeable.
And lastly, for the
Restore workflow,
the users create a
second DB resource.
But this time, this DB resource
has one additional API field
that referenced back to
the SqlBackup resource.
Why we want to do this?
This because we want
to get the backup
file information from
the backup resource.
Using the backup file
name, the SqlDB controller
is able to fetch the correct
backup file from the underlying
network file system, and
then call the restore utility
to perform the restoration.
In the end, a new
cluster will be created
and the cluster will do
that with a backup data.
And Sunil will show us all
the workflows through a demo.
SUNIL ARORA: OK,
so I'm going to--
let me attach to the demo.
OK.
So with this, let's
look at what we have.
So right now I
have a GKE cluster.
And let me quickly check if
we have connectivity here.
So yeah, we have a
five node cluster here.
And we already have deployed
the controller in the cluster.
So let's look at the CRDs.
The first step would be let's
look at the CRDs installed
in the system.
So we have already
created two CRDs which
is sqldbs and sqldbbackup.
We can quickly look at
one of the CRDs here.
So yeah, you'll see
wherever in the earlier part
I showed the CR definition,
that's where we see pretty much
very similar to that here.
So now the next step
that you want to do
is I'm going to show the
config that we generated for--
let's look at user wants
to create a db instance.
So this is the config that looks
like for the db instance, where
you specify the name,
you specify what version
of the database you want to
use, what type of database
you want to use.
In this case, we're
using Postgres.
And then the disk information
for disk to use it on.
So we can do--
OK, before I dive into that--
so on the right-hand side, what
I have is think of this as
another application which
is running in the
cluster, which is going
to access the database which is
provisioned by when we submit
the DB1 resource.
So I'm going to apply db1.
And so you see the database
request is accepted.
We can examine the SqlDBs
by running kubectl get here.
So this is the part
I was explaining
earlier where these are the
columns that you can configure.
So since it's a--
yeah, so this became
ready pretty fast.
So let's look at--
we can access this on
this service endpoint.
So status is one where--
yeah, it is using the
status field here.
So we're using hard coding
the credentials here.
So we'll use that.
OK.
So we are in.
So you can see
that what we did is
we submitted the db1.yaml
using kubectl, not
using any new sort of tools
to work with our database.
And then we use the
existing primitives
like services to expose it.
And if you look at it as it is
using StatefulSet, so you can--
not here.
If you look at it, it
created a db1-statefulset,
which is actually
running the Postgres pod
and container inside it.
So now let's look
at-- we want to take
a backup, which is what the
Day 2 operation looks like.
So for backup, what you
want to do is, let's say,
this is also modeled as
another API, SqlBackup.
And in this case, it's
a very simple API.
We're saying we want to
just back up the db1.
And we want to save the
output in this file.
Now we can just apply
this in a similar way.
So this is like a Day 2
operation, you can imagine,
which is taking a backup.
Oh, OK.
Sorry.
So the backup is succeeded.
So yeah, I mean, depending
on the application
you can output whatever things
you want to output here.
So now the third step,
which is we want to restore,
which is another Day N operation
that we want to perform.
So restoration workflows,
what you want to do
is we'll be using db2 here.
We want to bring
another instance.
We want to restore from the
backup that we took earlier.
And we'll just use the backup
name, db1-backup, here.
So we just apply this.
And yeah, so with that,
we see db2 is also ready.
And maybe here,
additional things
could be done is that
this was restored
from this db or additional
data that can be shown here.
Now-- oh, OK.
We did not create any
entry in the previous
before taking backup.
So yeah, the idea was actually,
we'll create some data,
and then we'll take the backup,
and then we'll restore it.
We can still do that.
I think we have time.
So let's create
some entries here.
OK.
So I'm still connected to
the DB1 if you look at.
So DB1 has this.
JUN TEE: In this, can
you delete the DB2,
and then create the other?
SUNIL ARORA: Yeah, you
can actually delete--
so that is another thing which--
so we deleted the DB2, and we
want to take backup, as well.
So let's delete backup, as well.
OK, so now we want
to take the backup.
Let's do that.
Oh, sorry.
JUN TEE: You should
check the SqlBackup.
SUNIL ARORA: So, yeah.
Backup is succeeded.
So now we create the DB2 here.
So just repeating
the same thing here.
And this should restore from
the backup that we took earlier.
And we can look at--
OK, so DB2 is also ready.
So now what we can do is--
JUN TEE: Do you
want to check again?
SUNIL ARORA: Let's
connect to DB2.
Jun is not feeling
confident, but let's see.
OK.
We'll-- yeah.
We have that row.
So yeah, it's working.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so--
JUN TEE: --SqlDB again.
Do it so the server restores.
SUNIL ARORA: Oh, OK.
Yeah, it is ready.
Server restore.
JUN TEE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
As you can see,
the status of DB2
has changed to server restore.
SUNIL ARORA: Oh, OK.
I see what you mean there.
OK.
Yeah, so with that, you
looked at the Day 0 and Day N
operation, what it looked
like for an example.
So this is not a
production-ready SqlDB
operator.
So please don't use that in--
so I think that this,
it's pretty much
the end of our session.
So can we switch
back to the slide?
And I want to go over
the takeaways real quick.
Yeah, so the takeaways that I
would like to mention over here
is the first is that Kubernetes
offers really powerful API
extension mechanisms.
And if you look at some of
the product launches that
have happened at GCP like in
the past or now, Istio or Cloud
Native or Knative, all these are
built on top of those extension
points.
So that's the first takeaway.
The second one is, you can
manage complex application
using operator pattern, the
one that we showed earlier,
by extending Kubernetes.
That's a key takeaway.
And the third is
the Kubebuilder SDK,
which provides you all the
tools and the libraries
to extend Kubernetes.
So, yeah.
With that, I would leave
you with this slide,
where we have all the
links to the resources
that we saw today.
The operator code, the
Kubebuilder book, also this--
so Kubebuilder has an
active Slack channel,
so I've also put in
the link for that.
If you have any queries, you
can jump on the Slack channel
and ask about it.
And the code that
we showed today
is also open sourced under
GoogleCloudPlatform/k8s sqldb
operator.
So go through that.
And then we have mine and
Jun's GitHub handle and Twitter
handle, as well.
So feel free to reach out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]